the infamous damning memo about the just
terrible disgraceful depraved actions of
the FBI has been released after being
declassified by Donald Trump and it's of
absolutely no consequence
I usually when I call something a
nothing burger I usually call it a
nothing burger satirically I'm making a
joke about the rights use of that term
but the memo that was written by
Republican congressman Devin Nunez was
seen before its release as a sort of
possible destroyer of the Trump Russia
investigation it's been released I've
looked at it millions have looked at it
and it's nothing I mean it is truly
nothing in any way and the only real
impact of the memos release and the
uncertainty about the future of the US
political status quo visa V the Trump
administration was to crash the stock
market on Friday almost a 666 point
decline in the Dow Jones Industrial
Average on Friday amidst the chaos of
the release of this memo that made it
the biggest single day decline in a
couple of years and beyond that the only
real consequences are to show Devin
Nunez is merely the hyper-partisan of a
bomb thrower that we actually already
knew him to be and to confirm that
actually the FBI is really on to
something with their investigation this
once again to reset for you was the memo
that was going to confirm once and for
all that Robert Muller was on a partisan
witch hunt on the behalf of the FBI and
that he must be stopped it all must be
stopped and Mulder must be fired or
prosecuted or whatever but what does the
memo actually say well let's go through
it
the memo written by Devin Nunez alleges
that the infamous Christopher steel
Trump Russia dossier was an important
part of the FISA applications against
Carter page
again it asserts that it doesn't provide
evidence of that it's a memo from Devin
Nunez and even if true it's not a huge
deal right since more and more of that
Trump Russia dossier from Christopher
Steele has been corroborated after all
the memo asserts that the four FISA
surveillance applications were signed by
in different combinations fired FBI
director James Comey not when he was
fired right when he was the FBI director
Andrew McCabe Sally Yates Dana bunty and
rod Rosenstein and why wouldn't they be
right those were and are some of them
important officials who would of course
be involved in the signing of those FISA
applications the FBI
according to Devon new neces memo
authorized payments to a former British
intelligence operative Christopher
Steele for working on the dossier and
again according to Devon new neces memo
the FBI terminated its agreement with
Steele in late October when it learned
through reading articles in the media
that Christopher Steele had been talking
to the media
again this is unproven because Devon
newness is merely asserting these things
in his memo without actually having
provided the underlying intelligence nor
having seen it himself but we'll get to
that later but if it's true that the FBI
terminated its relationship with
Christopher Steele that indicates that
the FBI acted appropriately right they
initially hired a respected intelligence
officer and they subsequently stopped
working with him when they found out
that he was talking to the media that
means the FBI did the right thing the
FBI acted correctly and with integrity
not exactly the blockbuster destruction
of the FBI's integrity that we were led
to believe the memo would be and Nunez
alleges that the political origins of
the Steele dossier were known to senior
Department of Justice and FBI officials
but that the nature of that political
origin was
excluded from the fisa applications
that's an unproven assertion and again
even Devin Nunez himself hasn't seen
those FISA applications so let's take
the big picture of it if the memos
claims are 100% accurate it's still no
indictment whatsoever on Robert molars
investigation but the accuracy isn't
known since the memos writer congressman
Devin Nunez hasn't even seen the
intelligence that the claims are based
on and that's a key thing right Nunez
wrote a memo about what intelligence
documents say but those aren't documents
he saw and you don't have to take my
word for that here's Devin Nunez on
Brett Bayers fox news program and Bret
Baier asks him
did you see the documents that you wrote
about in the memo and Nunez says no I
didn't see him take a look at this occur
did you it's not a place we wanted to go
it's not a place we wanted to go but
it's where we had to go did you write it
myself trey gowdy
are two investigators and then obviously
checked by the lawyers and the rest of
our committee member did you read the
actual fysop applications
no I didn't the and this has been one of
these bogus news stories that have been
put out so the agreement we made with
the Department of Justice was to create
a reading room and allow one member and
two investigators to go over and review
the documents I thought the best person
on our committee would be the chairman
of the Oversight Committee trey Gowdy
who has a long career as a federal
prosecutor to go and do this that's
right he didn't read them he's trying to
tell Bret Baier and the American public
why it doesn't matter well one person
was designated to go and we had a
reading room and these are sensitive
documents the bottom line is that the
guy crying foul and saying it's all
terrible it's immoral it's illegal
didn't read the intelligence that his
own memo is based on and before the
release of the memo the memo had the
power of myth right the right could
guess they could predict they could fear
monger what was actually in the memo
the memo has now been released they
can't fear monger anymore they just have
to lie about it because the memos
contents if true which we don't know the
truth of it barely registers as even
remotely notable and the guy who wrote
the memo Devon Nunez didn't even see the
intelligence that the memo is supposedly
based on
but for many trumpets it never really
mattered what was in the memo right
FoxNews will still insist that it's
shocking
Trump is insisting that the FBI is in
tatters and the memo proves that there's
no collusion which of course has nothing
to do with the content of the memo
whatsoever The Drudge Report a
right-wing online news aggregation
website has been running headline after
headline about the FBI and quote
disgrace and the truth is to any
clear-thinking individual that this
entire so-called scandal is another
laughable attempt to discredit Robert
Muller even ignoring that what is in the
memo was totally cherry-picked
and taken out of context and arguably
inaccurate if this memo is the best they
can do the entire case against Robert
Muller is just an utter and pathetic
joke and they they told us it would
expose corruption it would expose crimes
it would expose horrible immorality all
that was really exposed by the memo is
that Robert Moeller's investigation has
a very solid basis and there's really no
reason to be concerned whatsoever about
Robert Muller is some kind of partisan
hack on a witch-hunt of any kind and all
of a sudden I don't know if you saw this
but after the memos release Republican
congressman trey Gowdy put out a tweet
shortly after he announced he's leaving
Congress altogether and now it's all
starting to make more sense trey Gowdy
tweeted quote while this memo raises
serious concerns about the FISA process
I have been and remained confident in
the overwhelming majority of the men and
women serving at the FBI
and the DOJ as I have said repeatedly I
also remain 100% confident in Special
Counsel Robert Muller the contents of
this memo do not in any way discredit
his investigation more and more it
appears that trey gowdy choosing to
leave congress at this time is to get
away from the atrocity of the political
attempts to interfere in robert Muller's
investigation even redstate.com which is
a conservative publication is
questioning the accuracy of the memo it
points out first that the memo is
summarizing intelligence that we haven't
actually seen which I've been telling
you as well that Devon Nunez hasn't seen
and that we know the memo is wrong about
at least one thing which is on the
public record check out what Devon Nunez
says about James Combes 2017 testimony
this is from the memo okay in Devon
Nunez memo he writes according to the
head of the FBI's counterintelligence
division assistant director bill
pre-snap corroboration of the steel
dossier was in its infancy at the time
of the initial page FISA application
referring to Carter page after Steele
was terminated a source validation
report conducted by an independent unit
with an FBI assess Steele's reporting as
only minimally corroborated yet in early
January 2017 director Comey briefed
president-elect Trump on a summary of
the steel dossier even though it was
according to his June 2017 testimony
salacious and unverified Nunez is saying
in his memo that James Comey said in
June that the steel dossier is salacious
and unverified just not true
we know that that's not true James Comey
never said that Comey was asked in June
of 2017 whether he had confirmed the
allegations of the dossier and Comey
said he can't answer that in an open
setting and that the only time he said
and rather the only time Comey used
those words salacious and unverified was
when he said he briefed Trump about
salacious and
verified claims within the dossier so to
be perfectly clear James Comey testified
that he briefed Trump on the salacious
and unverified elements of the dossier
Devon Nunez characterized James Comey as
having called the entire dossier
salacious and unverified it's not true
Devon Nunez said something that either
he knew to be untrue or he deliberately
distorted or is ignorant of in his memo
and if that's the case why do we trust
anything in the memo whatsoever the only
success of this memo was creating an
alternate conversation about
discrediting Robert Muller period the
memo has exposed no wrongdoing it has
not discredited Robert Muller as someone
who cannot be trusted or is carrying out
a partisan witch hunt and maybe that's
all that Republicans can hope for at
this point which is just to distract
from the reality of the Trump Russia
investigation being carried out by
robert muller send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show and we'll
be talking about this more throughout
the week the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership